- Kelly Clarkson show always
closes out with one last story
to kind of brighten your day.
So here it goes, "This
is what I'm liking".
(upbeat music)
A third grade teacher in Georgia
wanted to give the students
a little extra motivation to work hard
and to be good to one another.
So he promised if they gave
their all to this studies
and stayed out of trouble,
he'd give them each a very
special Christmas gift.
When the holidays rolled around,
he'd delivered big time,
giving each kid a brand new
pair of designer sneakers.
So we have this very cool
educator on the line right now.
Let's talk to him.
Hi Anthony, how are ya?
- Hey, how y'all doing everybody?
Nice to meet ya all.
- [Jay] Good to see you.
So why did you do this?
Well, I kind of know, but go ahead.
- Why did I do it?
While I was in college, I had a professor
named Dr. Wethertine that
always taught us to be the one.
And so I wanted to do something
different for my kids,
if they put in the work.
So I told my kids from
the first day of school,
you come in, apply pressure.
You show growth in the different studies
that we have in our classroom,
also the different programs,
I'll reward you.
But the big kicker was the big three.
Be ready, be respectful, be responsible.
And so no suspensions, no
detentions, no bullying,
but also showing respect
amongst other adults,
not just myself, even
though I'm not watching.
So literally they had
to work all year long
and they showed the work.
They applied pressure and so
feel its right to reward them
with the shoes.
- [Jay] Well, that's terrific.
Were the kids-
Were they shocked when
they saw their sneaker.
Look at that.
- Shocked is a understatement.
So the way I did it is,
I would go to the mall
and take pictures of random shoes.
And so I had already wrote down,
their different shoe sizes
and I would come back in and I say,
well look.
I'd go to each kid, and I say,
let me pick out these shoes
for my niece and my nephew.
And so they'll look at
the shoes and they'll say
either they liked them or they didn't.
And I said, all right.
So if I bought this shoe,
would you wear them?
Will my niece and nephew like them?
And they say yes, then I would go with it.
If they said no, then I wouldn't,
and I would go back to the drawing board.
So the day they open their shoe boxes,
they was like, Mr. K,
these the shoes I picked.
it's my size.
And they take pride on them by
wearing the shoes at school.
And that's the big thing for me.
I don't want to buy them
anything they didn't like,
but also something that they took pride in
and they enjoy to see, and they
wear them almost every day.
So, but it wasn't all on me.
It was a teamwork effort.
- [Jay] You know, I'm here
because I had great teachers
like you when I was a kid.
I had a teacher that said,
"Hey, you should think about
being a comedy writer."
It never occurred to me
until the teacher gave me
that impetus, you know?
So thank you my friend.
Thank you from me,
and thank you for all the others as well.
- My pleasure.
- I'm liking your post right now
and that's not all.
Our season long partner Pilot Pen,
makers of the friction go-to erasable pen
of the Kelly Clarkson
Show wants to celebrate
those creating
fearlessness, just like you.
So they're giving you a check for $1,000.
So thank you my friend, thanks a lot.
- Wow.
- There you go,
You got 'em buddy.